- I bet you 20 bucks someone is gonna say,
'Let's throw another
shrimp on the barbie'.
(upbeat music)
- Alright here, (mumbles)
you've never made this one.
- Well (mumbles) I am jabber,
just jabber (mumbles).
Can I get you to say with me,
Ha boy ya ya.
- Ha boy ya ya.
- It's me after half a beer.
- There are some parts of Australia,
where the Aussie accent is so thick,
I can't even understand it.
- The thing that does now,
is Australians love to merge words.
Whether it be on purpose or not.
- I can confirm that's
how a lot of Aussies speak
in country towns.
So Anchorman, you came pretty close.
You did a good job.
- Now just goes to (mumbles)
a bunch of malarkeys.
- They put in words that
we never use like malarkey.
- When you hear an Australian
accent in a Hollywood film,
it does stand out like dog's balls.
- You're alright for a black fella.
- It's a shame that he's
saying something pretty racist.
- Yeah.
- But at the same time,
it's not that shocking
if that's his accent.
- I know that's an Australian actor,
but that accent turned way up.
- I'm gonna report this to
me member of Parliament.
Hey Gus, I got something to report to you.
- I'm from a small town,
and our local member of Parliament
did live close by and that's
how my dad did approach him.
- I'm want to take this all
the way to the Prime Minister.
- I hate that this is out
because it's a representation
of who we are.
- Hey Mr. Prime Minister.
- If you're looking for Malcolm Tumbull
there's a pretty good chance
that's he's just like floating
in a little ring drinking
a can of Fosters.
- The last time we did
have a prime minister
go in the water, he went missing.
- I like it.
I feel like it just takes the
piss, but not offensively.
- It's hilarious.
It's just a bit of fun.
- If people are thinking this
is offensive to Australia,
every other episode of the Simpsons,
is making fun of America.
Even this episode.
- Not a lot of Jewish
people where you're from?
- Ahh, no.
I did do Fiddler On The
Roof though in high school.
It was like me and some aboriginals.
It was really Jewish.
- So whenever aboriginal people come up
in Hollywood movies it's usually just as
like the butt of the joke
or anything like that.
- When I cheap gags like
that, it's kind of like
Oh, God, yet again.
Are you serious?
And I do wonder whether like
an international audience
see that and actually really
think that we're that stupid.
I hope not.
- To be an Aussie on
camera, doesn't mean you
have to be full bogan.
- Doesn't matter if you're a small (bleep)
or a big (bleep)
You can play these guys (bleep)
got a big barrel on (bleep)
just smack him (bleep)
(bleep)
- Lots of swearing.
- Yeah.
- Accurate.
- (bleep) Accurate.
- He's fun, he's laid-back,
and I guess at our core, that's
what most of us Aussies are.
- And when we are around Americans,
we do kind of exaggerate
our Australian accent
and culture because we
want to be that cool person
in their eyes.
- It was like they had
Gogglebox on in my apartment.
- So that was spot on.
It's an Aussie trying to get an American
onto Australian beer and
watch Australian sport.
Aussies are real guilty for that.
- After oday, I definitely
saw the stereotypes
that I knew I would see.
It's the same stuff over and over again.
- Obviously it would be cool to get like
a little bit more variety.
- A bit of diversity.
- Yeah.
- Would be nice.
- I mean a lot of it was
just taking the piss on us
and as Australians, we're pretty chill
and we just don't give a (bleep).
- All of these portrayed us
as kind of uncultured yobos.
And that's not true, you (bleep).
- In Australian shows, if you
see an American character,
we'll portray them as
a big, fat, loudmouth.
Then, how is that different to them just
making us out as bogans?
- It's all fun, it's all banter, and--
- It's funny.